merci merci d'être venus aussi nombreux
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui je vais essayer de vous
parler de ce que j'aime je vais vous
parler de ma passion et je suis venu
pour m'amuser parce que c'est vraiment
comme ça que je peut vous toucher
beaucoup d'entre vous ont énormément
d'expérience souvent beaucoup plus que
moi du moins dans plein de domaines
je vais essayer de vous parler d'un
endroit que j'ai déjà bien explorer et
d'une technologie où j'ai vraiment
creuser longtemps on va parler de la
blocs chaîne et on va parler des crypto
monnaie alors avant de vous dire qu'est
ce que c'est comment ça marche
déjà qu est ce que ça va changer eh bien
à peu près tout surtout là où l'être
humain est compétent c'est à dire la
communication les changes la
transmission on communiquait en échange
toute la journée
c'est là dedans que l'espèce humaine a
été très très très performante
c'est ça qu'on va essayer de
révolutionner c'est ce canal de
discussion qu'on va essayer d'établir
pour ne plus pouvoir jamais
l'interrompre et pour qu'on puisse
conserver toujours un dialogue
intelligent et bienveillant ensuite la
blocs chaîne qui va servir à beaucoup
plus que de simples échanges parce que
le dialogue c'est également du coup la
transmission la preuve que nous sommes
propriétaires de la transmission cette
propriété les changes
tout ce qu'on tout ce sur quoi on a basé
notre économie quand est-ce que ça va
arriver
parce qu'internet ok on conceptualise
même si on sait pas vraiment comment ça
fonctionne techniquement aujourd'hui
c'est abordable lusage on l'a on a tous
notre téléphone on communique tous
on est tous connectés aux caisses à ses
acquis maintenant ça va arriver qu'en
cent vingt ans pour que l'espèce humaine
arrive dans la première ère industrielle
quatre-vingt dix ans sur la deuxième
quand on a une première technologie on
va beaucoup plus vite sur la seconde 35
ans entre la découverte du protocole et
le fonctionnement d'internet et internet
comme on le connaît aujourd'hui
et encore avec la technologie qu'on a
développés on arrive à faire d adoption
massive de nouvelles technologies très
rapidement la bloque chaîne existe déjà
depuis dix ans auquel est connu depuis
trois ou quatre ans ça fait peu de temps
qu'elle commence à devenir connu le
bitcoin je pense que vous en avez au
moins entendu parler même si vous
connaissez pas et la technologie sur
lequel repose le bitcoin s'appelle la
blocs chaîne et on commence à en
entendre parler beaucoup aujourd'hui ça
va se dessiner et ça va s'appliquer sur
neuf
à tous d'ici quatre à cinq ans je pense
en tout cas ce sera pas beaucoup plus
long si ce n'est pas le cas puisque ça
va très très vite et que c'est utilisé
de plus en plus aujourd'hui je vais pas
vous pouvoir vous parler de tout ce
qu'on peut faire avec cette technologie
c'est une pâte à modeler cette
technologie et c'est pas une pâte à
modeler qui va créer des solutions
c'est une pâte à modeler qui va nous
créer des outils sur mesure pour
répondre à nos solutions et pour
répondre à nos problèmes donc on va
réellement pouvoir combler énormément de
choses avec ça je vais donc essayer de
vous transmettre vraiment la passion que
j'ai pour ça pourquoi ça m'empêche de
dormir
et pourquoi je suis convaincu que ça
peut améliorer ce que l'homme est
aujourd'hui alors déjà ça vient d'où la
blocs chaîne en 2008 il ya eu ce qu'on
appelle la crise des subprimes une
grosse crise économique
grosse remise en question du système
bancaire car ce sont les banques
ces banques des entreprises que l'on ne
remet tait jamais en question qui ont
fait une grosse erreur des grosses
erreurs des erreurs elles ont perdu
énormément d'argent et les gouvernements
ont eu deux choix premièrement les
célébrants couler autant vous dire que
si vous apprenez demain que votre banque
fait faillite
ça veut dire qu'on n'avait plus d'argent
plus rien si vous avez tous mis là bas
vous n'avez plus rien du tout c'est pas
grave vous recommencerez ça c'est le
premier point le deuxième point c'est de
se dire ok on peut pas faire ça aux gens
les pauvres le gouvernement va financer
pour payer la dette des banques
on va prendre l'argent des particuliers
pour ça et c'est vous encore c'est
génial
pas de problème à ce moment là en plus
de cette injustice extraordinaire que
y'a pas gêner tant de monde que ça parce
qu'il ya quand même des gens qui sont
passés totalement à côté de cette crise
énorme qui a eu il ya quand même eu une
personne qui s'est dit mais attendez
qu'est ce qui se passe demain si le
distributeur ne fonctionne plus ma carte
elles marchent pas qu'est ce que je fais
qu'est ce que vous faites
qu'est ce que vous faites si votre carte
bleue marche plus ou si quand vous
appelez la banque personne ne vous
répondra plus rien qui marche au revoir
bankroll et bien c'est très simple il se
passe plus rien on peut plus communiquer
alors c'est pas grave on retournera au
troc si vous êtes boulanger vous irez
changer votre pain à edf pour avoir
l'électricité chez vous vous irez
changer votre pain pour avoir vos séries
netflix ça va être compliqué de les
contacter tout ce que vous tout ce dont
vous avez besoin vous allez devoir
échanger ce que vous avez en échange en
fonction des métiers que vous allez
avoir ça va être compliqué enfin bref on
ne peut pas avec l'avancée de l'humanité
comme on l'a eue aujourd'hui revenir ans
arrières jusqu'au troc c'est pas
possible et cette personne ce groupe de
personnes sept femmes où cet homme ce
groupe de développeurs je sais pas on
sait pas c'est qui mais il s'appelle où
elle s'appelle satoshi nakamoto une
entité c'est un pseudonyme et il a lâché
sur un petit forum qu'on appelle
également la caverne du web qui
s'appellerait dit
le concept un white paper en gros les
règles d'un nouveau système comment ça
pourrait fonctionner le bitcoin un moyen
d'échangé quelque chose à la base
c'était même pas de la valeur ça valait
rien du tout évident quand et comment
des gens pourraient s'échanger 100 tiers
de confiance sans une banque ou sans une
assurance ou sans un autre organisme
comme une entreprise ou un gouvernement
qui va dire ok cette transaction je la
veux bien celle là je la vérifient celle
là je la bloque non vraiment un système
qui est totalement inarrêtable
le seul moyen c'est d'arrêter totalement
internet sur la planète entière
et encore il ya déjà des gens qui se
base sur des blocs chaînes qui sont
connectés et qui fonctionne par
satellite au cas où un jour quelqu'un
coupe internet
on sait jamais à ce moment là cette
personne avait établi un bon concept un
moyen qui permettrait toujours à la
démocratie de rester en échange
ça vient de là à la basse et un bon
c'est une personne qui a voulu faire
quelque chose de bien un mouvement
social et pour vous dire à quel point
ces personnes qui l'ont créée en garder
un bon stock de bitcoin pour eux et
pourtant l'année dernière quand le
bitcoin est monté jusqu'à 20000 dollars
ils ont rien vendu ils ont rien toucher
ils n'ont même pas pris leur argent
c'était vraiment une bonne action
sociale du moins c'est ma conviction
c'est encore évidemment des grands
débats puisqu'il n'y a pas vraiment de
réponses précises à ses questions
cette personne elle a voulu créer les
changes décentralisée pour ça la
décentralisation vous connaissez déjà
humber ok il ya un beur qui gère le
système et qui prend des frais un peu
comme une blocs scène mais globalement
c'est des particuliers qui vont conduire
des particuliers airbnb vous avez un
appartement il ya des gens qui ont
besoin d'un appartement
ça a été vite fait de faire le lien quoi
et bien c'est de la décentralisation
encore sauf qu'on peut aller beaucoup
plus loin
alors comment ça fonctionne à blocs
chaîne techniquement imaginer un livre
géant on le met juste à côté de moi vous
l'imaginez tous il est juste là et on
écrit tout ce qui se passe mes
déplacements
un petit peu hasardeuse sur ce tapis
vous tenu à vous map mes paroles toutes
mes erreurs de langage
ce que vous faites vous si vous êtes sur
votre téléphone les tweets si quelqu'un
tire un stylo ici qui l'attiré il est
parti d'où il est arrivé où il est
quelle couleur on écrit tout de telle
sorte que si votre collègue qui est
vraiment en retard parce que s'il arrive
maintenant il est vraiment en retard
s'ils rentrent dans cette salle il va
pouvoir comprendre non seulement tout ce
qui se passe ici tout ce que nous avons
dit tout ce qui s'est passé mais
également le contexte de cette histoire
pour vraiment prendre du recul il va
comprendre qu'est-ce qu'on était en
train de dire mais où on en était le
sentiment a quitté ce stylo il va savoir
à qui il est ce stylo eh bien c'est
exactement comme ça là blocs chaîne
c'est un registre c'est un livre dans
lequel on écrit tout est donc si dans le
livre je crée mon livre et je vous dis
voilà il ya 100 pièces qui s'appelle et
owen coyle et bien si je vous dis que
j'en ai sens et que je vous en donne
deux avoue et bien dès la deuxième page
vous en avez deux donc j'en ai 98 on
peut pas le remettre en question on peut
pas modifier les pages passé parce que
ce livre là on en a tous une copie en
temps réel dans nos poches
une personne ne peut pas le modifier
c'est ça la décentralisation
alors évidemment c'est pas un livre et
des pages c'est une chaîne et des blocs
on met les informations dans les blocs
et ils sont liés par une chaîne temporel
qui avance en fonction du temps là blocs
chaîne tout simplement
alors là blocs chaîne elle est
intelligente l'être humain il a cinq
sens heureusement ça nous a permis de
non seulement comprendre notre
environnement l'odorat le toucher la
blocs chaîne on peut également la doté
d'intelligence grâce à ce qu'on appelle
des smart contracte en gros c'est un
contrat qui est connecté à la blocs
chaîne et qui va lui permettre d'être
intelligente par exemple on peut lui
connecter un gps et si tous les membres
qui l'utilisent accepte de donner leur
position la bloque chaîne sait où sont
ses membres imaginez à quel point la
blocs chaîne pourrait réfléchir à notre
place et à quel point elle pourrait nous
aider dans ce dialogue là on pourrait
mettre un horodatage vous avez une idée
vous voulez prouver que vous êtes le
premier actuellement c'est très
compliqué par contre vous pouvez
l'envoyer dans les blocs scène votre nom
votre prénom qui vous est expliqué voilà
j'ai eu cette idée à telle date
si quelqu'un l'a après vous pourrez
prouver que vous étiez le premier parce
que là blocs chaîne qui était doté d'un
horodatage vous étiez le premier à
envoyer une information dans un bloc en
disant non mais c'est moi qui ai fait ça
etc etc la blocs chaîne peut être très
intelligente pour vous donner un peu
plus pour vous puissiez plus vous
projetez je vous donnais de trois
exemples qui ont déjà été faits avec la
prochaine en espérant que ça vous donne
des idées qui n'ont pas encore été
faites et que vous pourrez appliquer
vous une assurance qui a fait un système
très simple quand on prend un avion on a
des assurances si l'avion a plus de deux
heures de retard
on peut se faire rembourser 50% de son
vol c'était compliqué faut appeler
l'assurance l'assurance m'appelle
aéroport est ce que l'avion était bien
en retard est ce qu'il avait bien un
ticket oui est-ce qu'il était majeur est
ce qu il avait payé
oui d'accord ok on va le contacter vous
êtes bien telle personne oui mais
envoyez moi votre rib
dès qu'on a reçues votre rib on va vous
rembourser sous 2 3 à 4 semaines et on
vous rembourse travaux 30 euros
après quatre heures de dialogue pour
vous mais également pour quelqu'un qui
travaille dans l'assurance est quelqu'un
qui travaille à l'aéroport et
l'assurance hédi ben nous on va prendre
un blog shane doc scène très connus
blocs chaîne de l'été rome l'une des
trois plus grosses blocs chaîne à
l'heure actuelle on va rajouter un
contrat intelligent qui est connecté à
tout le système aérien mondial et qui
est connecté à tout la base de données
d'axa est ce qu'on va faire c'est
qu'avec cette assurance
on va regarder instantanément dès qu' un
vol quel vol est en retard
est ce qu'un client ou une personne qui
avait pris le contrat d'assurance était
dans ce vol et avant même que sept
personnes descendent de l'avion qui est
en retard elle a été remboursée sur son
compte courant point terminée bien de
temps efficacité pertinence et on perd
pas de temps parce que c'est tout ce
qu'on a c'est notre plus grosse valeur
notre temps sur cette terre et on en
perd plus on peut également aller dans
un tout autre domaine
ça vous est déjà demandé ça vous est
déjà arrivé pardon d'aller à l'autre
bout de la planète et vous dire est que
mon forfait téléphonique va passer ou
est ce que quand je vais rentrer je vais
me prendre une facture et bien ça c'est
un problème qui n'existera bientôt plus
votre question sera est ce que je
pourrais être connecté à internet dans
ce pays là si je peux être connecté à
internet ou un satellite bien je vais
passer par une blocs chaîne c'est existe
déjà et déjà un téléphone comme ça
qu'ils existent et je vais pouvoir
échanger à toutes les personnes de la
planète qui sont connectés à sept blocs
chaîne
ce ne sont donc pas des toqués ne sont
donc pas des crypto monnaie que je vais
envoyer mes ce sont dans les blocs d
information peut-être sous forme de
tolkien dans laquelle il y aura marqué
le message que je veux faire passer un
autre individu et on va pouvoir
communiquer quelle que soit sa position
quelle que soit la personne en face de
nous on va pouvoir communiquer tout le
temps et on ne pourra plus être
interrompue ça ne peut pas être censuré
un gouvernement ne peut pas arrêter là
blocs chaîne encore moins une entreprise
on ne peut pas l'arrêter puisque c'est
gérer la blocs chaîne en elle-même est
géré par toutes les personnes qui
l'utilisent et qui met à jour ce livre
en permanence tous les utilisateurs de
la même façon il ya eu un super projet
ils ont créé ce qu'on appelle le sol
arkane si vous avez un panneau solaire
chez vous devez vous connecter
d'ailleurs si vous avez un panneau
solaire fait le ce serait intéressant
pour vous à chaque fois vous générez un
kilowattheures d'énergie verte
d'énergies renouvelables vous allez
recevoir un seul arkane alors soit vous
le revendez contre des euros on va vous
payer pour faire du bien à la planète et
pour que vous
cité à générer de l'énergie verte ou
alors vous pouvez réutiliser ce solar
coyne pour le jour où vous n'avez pas
assez d'électricité allait acheter
l'énergie verte de quelqu'un d'autre
par exemple encore une fois c'est des
particuliers à des particuliers qui vont
s'échanger ça alors c'est compliqué
d'échangés d'électricité entre nous mais
en attendant on va pouvoir communiquer
avec cette nouvelle monnaie qui a un
usage bien particulier ça c'était des
petits exemples qui me plaisent c'est ce
qu'on raconte c'est ce qu'on dit qu'il
existe déjà
y'en a plein d'autres essais des choses
extraordinaires qui ont déjà été
réalisés mais il ya également d'autres
situations dans lequel les crypto
monnaie elles peuvent servir les taux
ken block chaining cette technologie au
venezuela aujourd'hui c'est vraiment une
grosse crise économique 4% d'inflation
par jour c'est à dire que tout ce que
vous avez tous les jours ça vaut 4 % de
moins envie d'aller bosser et bien ce
qu'ils ont fait ces gens là c'est que du
coup avec leur bolivar consciente que
c'est la monnaie et du coup tous les
jours il allait vite dépensé il faut
vite dépensé elle vaut plus rien demain
donc on va dépenser maintenant il ya des
gens qui sont retournés au troc sa part
au fiasco il ya des gens qui peuvent
plus acheter à manger c'est vraiment la
guerre clairement il ya plus de
solutions jusqu'à c'était le bitcoin son
arrivée le bitcoin a explosé suite à la
demande de ce pays là et les gens en ont
acheté la barre et les gens communiquent
avec du bitcoin il en échange parce que
ça ne peut pas ça ne peut pas tomber
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui va être
échangé de particulier à particulier qui
va permettre aux gens de se ré échanges
et de la valeur et c'est comme ça que
beaucoup de témoignages que vous pouvez
retrouver sur internet de personnes qui
sont actuellement là en disant voilà on
a trouvé une solution d'échangé de la
valeur entre nous sans tiers de
confiance parce que le nôtre qui était
notre monnaie nationale mais il vaut
plus rien c'était des exemples c'était
des applications ce sont des faits réels
va y en avoir de plus en plus que ce
soit des applications des améliorations
de ce qu'on connaît ou de des problèmes
qui peut y avoir
mais en attendant je voulais vraiment
apporter votre attention sur un point
toutes les personnes que vous avez vu
parler aujourd'hui elles ont des
convictions
elle vous expliquer des choses qui font
pas elles essayent de vous dire regardez
ici si vous regardez pas tous les jours
et pourtant vous y êtes mais il ya plein
de solutions qui vont pouvoir être
trouvés grâce à par exemple cette
technologie il ya des gens qui
s'inquiètent parce que l'histoire n'a
pas été complète
on n'a pas parlé totalement de la vraie
histoire ou du moins on a dix qui s'est
passé dans notre ce qui s'est passé dans
notre passé du coup mais on a dit sous
un certain angle
du coup on pense que et on veut faire
toute la lumière il ya d'autres
personnes qui eux vont s'inquiéter sur
la trace qu'on va laisser sur internet
qu'est ce qu'il ya
qu'est ce qu'il ya comme photo de moi
sur internet comment je peux le retrouve
il ya d'autres personnes qui
s'inquiètent en disant comment on va
tirer notre patrimoine avec nous comment
est ce qu'on va faire pour aller très
très loin là bas pour essayer de
recommencer à zéro alors qu'on n'est pas
capable de le faire ici
et bien tout ça toute cette technologie
là va devoir être accompagné
l'avantagent de la blocs chaîne sait que
c'est un falsifiable on ne modifiera pas
le passé et ici en train de se créer
maintenant c'est à dire qu'au lieu de
faire quelque chose sans vraiment y
réfléchir et dans 50 100 200 ans se dire
où là on a fait des erreurs maintenant
il va falloir qu'on change les habitudes
qu'on change les moeurs il va falloir
qu'on répare nos bêtises
et bien cette technologie là les très
jeunes elle va s'appliquer très
rapidement dans les années qui viennent
et c'est aujourd'hui qu'on peut
peut-être en réfléchissant définir une
base bienveillante une base saine une
base pérenne parce que l'être humain au
21e siècle il a peut-être la capacité de
réfléchir de s'unir et de faire en sorte
qu'on baptise dès maintenant des choses
qu'on ne va pas avoir à déconstruire
dans son temps quand on se sera rendu
compte qu'on aura fait des bêtises que
ce soit vis-à-vis de notre planète ou
entre nous en échangeant je vous
remercie infiniment pour le temps que
vous m'avez accordée
[Applaudissements]